the more we learn about the school
shooting in Florida the more it appears
that a Broward County invention may have
played a role in what happened what am I
talking about
in 2013 Broward County and their new
school superintendent Robert Runcie had
a novel idea lower school expulsion Zinn
arrests by reducing police involvement
sounds simple they called it the promise
program preventing recidivism through
opportunities mentoring intervention
support and education it's quite an
acronym you see in 2011 into 2012 school
year Broward had the highest public
school related arrest record in the
state more than a thousand kids in that
year alone were arrested the Obama
administration Education Secretary Arne
Duncan and Attorney General Eric Holder
were so impressed by the promise plan
that it inspired their own new national
guidelines as it stands far too many
students far too many students across
this country are diverted from the path
to success by unnecessarily harsh
discipline policies and practices that
exclude them from school for really
minor infractions too often so-called
zero-tolerance policies however
well-intentioned they might be make
students feel unwelcome in their own
schools they disrupt the learning
process and they can have significant
and lasting negative effects on the
long-term well-being of our young people
well I'd say a violent kid whose
outbursts are tolerated week after week
leading years later to a school shooting
also has lasting negative effects on
young people and disrupts the learning
process Eric but I digress the Obama
bureaucrats incentivize Brower to go
even further awarding the district
nearly 54 million dollars in grants to
improve the lives of students in poverty
and students of color the standard to
show that their lives are actually
improving fewer arrests
schools less police involvement fewer
disciplinary problems at least on paper
so school administrators were basically
paid to deal with student crime in-house
and keep the cops off the premises had
Nicholas Cruz been arrested or charged
by police for bringing knives or bullets
to school or for other various
infractions threats and so forth he
might not have been able to buy that gun
he used to kill 17 people when CNN's
Jake Tapper pressed sheriff Scott Israel
about his office's approach to student
crimes he said this what you're
referring to is the promise program and
it's it's giving this school the school
has the ability what under certain
circumstances not to call the police not
to get the police involved on
misdemeanor offenses and take care of it
within this school it's a it's a it's an
excellent program what did we expect to
is gonna say until it helps a mass
killer maintain a clean record up to the
time of his shooting that is Broward
County Sheriff Union President Jeff Bell
revealed this to me last week they don't
want the police officers making arrests
on campus and they don't want the drugs
to be found on campus and they don't
want the warrants to be served on campus
because it looks like there's bad stats
at the school so I place a lot of blame
on the school board with that and some
of the programs that they've initiated
with the state attorney in the sheriff's
office in years past
for example the promise program the
problem is with them when that program
started we took all discretion away from
the law enforcement officers to an
effect an arrest if we choose to that
was stunning
now Broward School Superintendent Robert
Runcie sheriff Israel in the Obama
bureaucrats that created this perverse
incentive to hide student criminality or
downplay it have a lot of explaining to
do
by turning Broward schools and those
across the nation into these social
justice petri dishes they may have
facilitated a lunatic and there's
soft policies have turned our schools
into soft targets and that's the angle